today for our daily cancellation we
begin with a new poll that reveals
shifting cultural attitudes and
priorities as we know from experience
cultural attitudes and priorities very
rarely shift in the right direction and
I would say they have not in this case
either as New York Post headline reveals
most Americans don't judge adults who
still live with their parents now I'm
not going to get hung up on this point
but to be clear Americans do judge
adults who still live with their parents
it's just that they make positive as
opposed to negative judgments it's
actually impossible for a sentient
conscious conscious human being to not
judge other people we make judgments all
the time about everyone and everything
and every situation we encounter the
ability to make judgments to discern is
one of the most crucial things that
separates us from fish and lizards and
mice now this is not really relevant to
the topic at at hand but it's worth
stating for the record that there is
nothing wrong with judging other humans
in fact it is what makes you human your
ability to do that in any case here's
the article living with Mom and Dad
well-past childhood has become socially
acceptable according to a new survey the
vast majority of Americans believe
moving back in with your parents as an
adult is an understandable decision not
meriting judgment according to a new
survey by Harris pole for Bloomberg News
well except that understandable decision
is a judgment but again not the point
continuing indeed almost 90% of uh the
4,16 adults surveyed felt that amid so
much student debt such as such an
insecure job market and record-breaking
inflation there shouldn't be stigma
around the decision to live at home and
save it's a good thing because almost
half of Young Americans are currently
doing just that while no longer quite at
the record highs reached in the early
days of the coronavirus uh lockdowns
when nearly 50% of 18 to 29 year olds
lived with their family about 23 million
or 45% are currently cohabitating uh
with relatives that's the same rate as
the one that followed the Great
Depression while there used to be a
strong stigma against grown children not
living on their own it being seen as
them having failed to launch us
residents empathize with the larger
Financial Fallout impacting the housing
situations of Millennials and
genz so in summary lots of grown adults
are living at home with their parents
and our culture now generally finds that
Arrangement acceptable and it should be
said that our culture in this case
shockingly is not entirely wrong okay
there there are a few important caveats
when we talk about the uh adult living
with their parents in fact historically
in most societies including our own it
used to be standard practice for grown
children to live with their parents
families would remain together in the
same home or on the same
Homestead um and uh and that's how they
would live the nuclear family existed
alongside of and with the extended
multi-generational family multiple
Generations living together helping each
other working together to survive um
there is not only nothing wrong with
that sort of arrangement but it is to my
mind clearly superior to the modern
setup you know having families break up
into smaller units and fan out across
the country losing touch with each other
growing distant um not being around to
help and support each other this is all
very modern and it's hard to claim that
it's an
improvement the idea that kids should
leave the house at 18 and be gone
forever from the family home cut off
from from parental support that is a
recent Innovation the Baby Boomers may
not have entirely come up with this idea
but they are the ones who helped to make
it the default setting for a while uh
parents were determined to get their own
kids out of the house as quickly as
possible in many cases for no other
reason than the simple fact that they
didn't like having their kids around and
they didn't much enjoy being parents and
so they were eager to be done with it
they emptied the nest which often
included getting divorced either before
or after the kids left home a house
which was once home to mother and father
and children now was home to only the
mother as the family and the marriage
broke apart and eventually both parents
end up living in separate apartments on
different sides of town and the kid take
the kids take turns begrudgingly hosting
one parent or the other on holidays I
mean this is the this is the modern
Western approach to family life and it
is deeply sick and totally wrong in
pretty much every conceivable way so if
we are seeing a shift away from that
failed approach and back to a more
traditional more family Centric way of
life um that's a very good thing but
unfortunately that's not exactly what's
happening in many cases okay it's true
that some of the adults living with
their parents they do fall into this
traditional category these are
functional well-adjusted mature
contributing adults who choose to live
with their parents or have their parents
live with them either so that they can
take care of their parents or because
they want to have this
multi-generational family you know
living together set up um or they want
to you know be close to each other like
the old days and the adults in that
category they're doing nothing wrong in
fact I would like to adopt their
approach with my own
kids um I am personally not eager to
send all my kids off in six different
directions hundreds of miles apart so
that I only see them and my
grandchildren you know in the future a
few times a year at best um I mean if
that's what ends up happening I can't
stop them from moving away obviously but
but uh you know I I I would prefer if
that didn't happen I like the idea of
having my family all together and close
to each other but the problem is that
this only describes a certain fraction
of the adults who live with their
parents and I suspect it is not a
majority of that fraction on the other
end of the spectrum are the adult
children who live at home as children
they don't work they don't contribute
they watch TV they play video games they
sit around on their phones all day they
live in a state of Perpetual adolescence
and so that is really the crisis that's
the problem it's not simply living with
your parents it is being a Perpetual
adolescent that is the
issue and there are some people who who
pull that off even living on their own
they might live on their own but their
parents pay for the apartment their
parents pay the phone bill their parents
pay everything and so they're not living
in their parents house but they might as
well be they're they're still living
under their
parents
um and for people like this if they're
at home and they're not at home because
they want to be close to their families
but rather because they want to avoid
responsibility and they want to avoid
work and
sacrifice adults like this for example
watch welcome to the day in the life of
a 24-year-old that still lives with her
appearance after get ask why I don't
move out if I can afford to and the
truth is I am lazy and honestly your
Toronto prices is just cheaper to be
nicer to my mom so I made these protein
waffles for breakfast for everyone
they're so good they're $20 cies for the
whole F and then I got ready to bully my
parents into buying things that I want
then I noticed that my mom decided to
copy my outfit har look how cute this
camera is I'm obsessed then I have some
pictures printed then went to the
aquarium just kidding we went grocery
shopping because they never know what to
feed their allergy child then I have to
play with my new toy made some dinner it
do my day
okay okay so that is a 24-year-old
living like a four-year-old and she is
obviously far from alone here's just one
more uh example watch a realistic day in
my life as an unemployed 26-year-old who
lives with her parents today I woke up
at 3:00 p.m. because these days I'm just
too depressed to wake up and I just go
back to bed because I feel like it and
then my mom made me made us dinner cuz I
live with my parents this is all the PCH
we had and we had my birthday cake cuz
it was my birthday last week and the
little heads are on fire which is so
cute and then I got myself kind of
together and sat down on my desk and got
myself to do some coloring which only
lasted about 5 minutes and then I
decided to do my skin care cuz I thought
it would make me feel better and first I
flossed cuz I love flossing cuz I think
it's really important and I did my
double cleanse cuz I had sunscreen on
from the morning even though I went back
to bed after putting on sunscreen then I
did my skin care which is like a toner
pad an ample and a lotion because I was
lazy today and that's about
it oh okay so she woke up at 3:00 p.m.
ate some food did some coloring did her
skincare routine and then went back to
bed I can't even say she's living like a
four-year-old because even my
four-year-old uh has more responsibility
around the house than this 26-year-old
woman like my four-year-old would not be
allowed to live that way this is a
26-year-old living a life so sedentary
that she may as well be an infant she
she is a 26-year-old living like a 26
week old when we think of adults who
live with their parents you know this is
who we're thinking of which admittedly
isn't fair to those in the first
category we talked about but the fact is
that this other category exists and
there are probably Millions who fall
into it and it is a severe problem in
our
society if the idea of kids leaving the
home and moving far away and effectively
severing themselves from their extended
family is a modern and mostly negative
development than kids staying at home
and doing nothing and contributing
nothing and remaining in a state of
adoles limbo is even more modern and
significantly worse everyone here at the
office loves the genu Cell Dark Spot
Corrector and I love it too because now
everyone around me has faces that I can
stand to look at sort of you might be
asking what does it even do rather well
if you have sunspots dark spots
discoloration or dry skin the genus Cell
Dark Spot Corrector will help those
blemishes disappear in front of your
very eyes Kimberly from Youngstown Ohio
says my appearance has approved so much
since using genus cell I love all my
genus cell products and my skin looks
younger well now it's your return to
feel just like Kimberly but hurry
because this sale is ending very soon
take advantage of Jus cell's most
popular package which includes the
Beloved Dark Spot Corrector this package
also includes the genus cell's classic
under eye treatment you get all these
products for almost 70% off genus cell
is so confident in their products that
you can try them for yourself completely
risk-free if you don't see immediate
results you'll get your money back go to
genucell.com Walsh and start looking
years even decades younger tomorrow say
hello to the best skin you've ever had
at genucell.com Walsh that's
genucell.com
what you just saw in those Tik Tok
videos was a kind of decadence that
could have only been enjoyed by the
children of pharaohs and Emperors in
earlier times you know the the idea of
of of living every day not doing
anything and just lazing around the
house and yet you can still survive and
eat in earlier times you would have had
to
been uh insanely wealthy to to live that
way but now we have a generation of
people who have the vices of the uber
wealthy but without the wealth it's like
the worst of all worlds you're as lazy
and
decadent as as we imagine maybe the
child of an extremely wealthy person
might be except you're not
wealthy and this is the case for lots of
20 and even 30s somethings living with
their parents they say that the economy
is tough and job opportunities are
scarce and all that and yet they're
doing almost nothing to improve their
situation they're putting in no effort
at all you know when when you don't have
a job finding a job is supposed to be a
full-time job you should be putting in
eight to nine hours a day every single
day finding a job why wouldn't you you
got nothing else to do with your time
and if you're living with your parents
then you don't even have to worry about
feeding yourself or anything like that
everything's taken care of you got
nothing but
time and so why are you not
spending 8 nine 10 hours a day finding a
job and I guess what if you put that
kind of effort into it you'd find a job
in like a
week these are not poor and desperate
people scrounging to get by they're lazy
and stagnant content to remain attached
to their parents like Barnacles
indefinitely their relationship with
their parents has become
parasitic and worst of all they don't
even want anything better for themselves
the struggling economy is a smokees
screen for them they use it as an excuse
but the truth is that they lack even the
desire to provide for themselves they
have no ambition they have no Drive
again this does not describe every adult
living with their parents but it is it
does describe a certain large
preponderance of
them and for those in that group the
only remedy at this point is for their
parents to cut the umbilical cord
finally and
completely kick them out of the house
let them really struggle for the first
time in their
lives give them the chance to sink or
swim because you know what either option
would be better than floating like human
Driftwood through
life as I'm always preaching every human
life depends on work no human being can
remain alive without work but if you
will not do any of the work for yourself
then you are living off of the work of
others but nobody especially no young
adult should have that
luxury it is not even a luxury it's a
curse it Dooms you to a mediocre
unimpressive uninteresting pointless
Meandering
life and that is why ultimately the
parents who let these kinds of kids live
at home with them are the ones who are
deservedly canceled if You' like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page hope to see you there
Godspeed